Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 21st,
2016 what's going on?
How are you this wonderful gloomy Monday where I'm at.
It's gloomy out here.
Chance of fucking shower,
which should be great.
You know,
because how it works out here in Los Angeles is we basically every three years
we get all of our rain for three years.
Essentially.
That is how it works.
And I know a lot of people think like,
oh my God,
that must be so wonderful.
You know,
you just wake up every day knowing the sun's going to shine.
It fucking drives you crazy after a while.
Um,
fortunately I travel enough.
I get on the road again.
Chickaboom took upon meat and Trump fans and some bone for that old guy.
What the,
what the fuck's Bernie Sanders?
He wants to take all the money from the fucking enrich and give it to the board
and Donald Trump,
he doesn't like Mexicans.
And Hillary's going to drive right between those two fucking lunatics.
Ah,
good Lord.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I haven't been watching it,
but I know that that's what's going to happen.
It all you broads out there who are fucking excited to finally get a fucking
clam into the fucking Oval Office.
Okay,
I understand.
I don't understand.
I'm not a fucking woman.
I don't know what it's like to walk by a construction site and have a bunch of
people communicate that they find me sexually attractive.
You know,
you know,
there is a positive way to look at that.
If you take away all the sexual assault vibe from it.
It's kind of a,
you know,
a nice tip of the construction cat.
You know,
I don't walk by and they go,
oh,
you funny motherfucker.
I get nothing.
I get silence.
I get snickers.
Hey fucking Casper.
Right.
I may make fun of my lack of melody is a Melatonin pigment.
Melatonin isn't that fucking,
uh,
I forget that's a fruit and that's not the skin cancer.
Don't you need Melatonin?
Oh Jesus.
Who gives a fuck?
I'm just saying,
right.
Just because somebody has a vagina
doesn't mean because you also have a vagina that they are going to do what's
right for you.
Think about all the presidents that have had dicks,
which is far as I know,
has been all of them,
but you never know.
You never know.
Back in the day there were no cell phone pictures,
right.
There was no video cameras.
You had no idea.
You know,
I,
you know Andrew Jackson and he could have been like,
you know,
he looks like one of those broads on fucking,
uh,
the fuck's at of that showed the golden girls.
He looked like one of the golden girls,
sort of their hip or younger one.
You know,
he really had that middle of the ground,
you know,
that.
Is it a chick?
Is it a dude?
Roger Daltrey early eighties haircut,
you know,
except was a public wig over there.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
I'm just saying just because somebody has the same fucking thing as you does not
mean that they're going to do what's good for you or that you're now going to
get more stuff like clock cheese in the White House.
Doesn't that mean I get a corner office?
No,
it doesn't fuck the,
you have to do with her.
I got to admit.
Yeah.
If I see a redhead achieves something,
I don't feel excited like,
oh,
it's only a matter of time before that comes around my way and I know what
you're taking.
Oh,
what build.
It's not like red heads are a minority.
Yes,
we are.
And unseen minority.
I told you,
walking amongst you,
listening in on your conversation,
reading your emails.
We're here.
Man.
Went from another port from fucking Mars,
the Red Planet.
This is where we came from.
We came here,
right?
We look just like you guys,
but then we fucked up when we ended the atmosphere.
Right?
We got a little fucking singed up there and burned our pubes.
Oh my God.
It's so fucking gloomy.
Day is a good God damn gloomy day.
I hope the fucking,
the goddamn clouds part.
Um,
anyways,
older,
oh,
freckles is looking for a new car.
I'm looking for a new car,
baby,
a new car.
And I got to admit,
I actually feel like I'm,
uh,
you know,
like leaving the Prius behind.
You know,
I've had the,
I had almost eight years with the thing runs like a fucking top.
I Dunno,
I just want to get something new.
I got a buddy who might buy it.
I Dunno.
I'm a frugal son of a bitch.
I'm probably just going to go look.
But you know,
it's a good,
a good time to look for a fucking car was on a rainy day,
you know,
all those fucking tool shed fucking salesman.
They are the worst.
The car seat,
car smell salesmen are the lowest of the low of fucking salespeople.
And you know what's funny?
They know it.
They wouldn't even lie about it.
They know what the fuck they do.
I mean,
they,
they had like one rung below a drug dealer,
at least with drugs.
You know,
you get some sort of a high,
well I guess when you buy a car you do,
you know,
I don't know.
Fuck they,
they are just like,
I know,
the great thing is is I really don't need a car.
So I'm in a great negotiating a negotiable negotiator to go shore with a hollow
position.
I was going to let go and be like,
yeah,
I liked that and this is what I'm going to pay a.
So go discuss it with your manager and come back and come back with that number
or something less or I'm just going to get my car.
You trade that in?
Nope.
I could sell it to my buddy or I could just drive across the street.
Not Take on all this fucking debt.
Just go get myself a ham sandwich.
Huh?
What do you say this stupid tie.
Go talk to your manager.
Um,
I always talk a good game and then I go in there and I get fucked because at the
end of the day I just,
I don't want to be there and it's just,
I don't give a shit if it costs me a few grand more.
It's like,
how much more do I have to pay to get you to shut the fuck up?
And they know it.
You know what I mean?
You have a,
a women talk about how guys just wear them down sometimes and they just see,
just sort of blow him to shut him up and just get them on their way.
That's what car salesmen do to make.
No,
they don't blow me.
They,
uh,
they just fought.
They do wear me down though.
They fucking wear me down and I'm just like,
f you know,
I,
I don't okay.
I at,
when I bought my Prius,
I was just like,
I went in,
I said,
listen,
I'm paying this and that's it.
And I go,
well,
we're not giving you it for that.
It's a hot car.
We sell like three a day.
And I'm like,
well then I'm leaving.
And then they go,
all right.
And then I went,
all right,
I'll pay what you want me to.
I am the fucking worst.
I want all you salesmen to know that a sucker just went through the doe.
Um,
that's going to be Megan about fucking two hours.
all right,
what the hell am I?
What am I talking?
Oh,
you know,
it's,
I'm actually really enjoying.
I actually had a cigar.
I told you for the first time,
and I got to admit,
I kind of didn't.
I liked it.
I liked it,
did it,
but there was way more.
Um,
I don't like this shitty taste in my fucking mouth the next day.
Then there was that.
I enjoyed that and I am on the precipice of a,
just straight up quitting those fucking things,
which should make me feel really good to be honest with you.
Like I said,
if I keep smoking these things this summer,
I'm a four year smoker,
something I'd never thought I'd be.
Now I'm not going to start crying right now.
Like some broad that just won an award pretending to be a nurse.
You know,
some fucking show you like me.
He really liked me.
Um,
I,
I don't,
uh,
I don't need that shit in my life,
although I gotta admit I've,
I,
I do enjoy,
do I enjoy them?
I think I remember that I enjoyed the last one I had.
I liked,
I liked it,
but I didn't a afterwards I was like,
well,
Jesus Christ is fucking taste in my mouth.
So,
um,
yeah,
dude,
you guys consider me a smoker if I smoked one new year's Day,
the Superbowl,
my birthday,
and then on one of those Jewish holidays in September,
I think I needed,
I needed for sticking like once every three months.
What the fuck?
Hey,
my birthday's June,
so I come out of the gate,
right?
Boom.
January 1st I smoke one,
and then February 3rd is the super bowl and then it's nothing in March.
Nothing in April,
nothing in May.
And then in June for my birthday,
Bam,
I smoke one.
And then,
um,
I don't know,
maybe that big college game I go to every year,
you know,
I dunno.
I have no idea.
I figured,
you know,
say,
oh,
I remember what the fuck I was going to tell you guys.
Remember I was telling you last time there was something I wanted to tell you
but I,
I couldn't remember what it was.
Um,
I tried to make Gnocchi the other night.
Did I tell you that?
And you'll keep however the fuck you say,
what a God damn fucking disaster.
Fucking disaster.
You know what?
This is base.
It just tasted like,
you know,
just imagine what cookie dough would tastes like minus everything that makes it
tastes good.
It was just blobs of Shit,
blobs of flower.
Um,
what happened was wet was,
I was a,
I went on the Internet and I was watching these fucking chefs make this shit.
And what they do is when they go to mix it,
they fast forward through it or they just jump cut because they feel that it's
boring and that no one's going to watch the rest of it.
And that right there,
that's the key right there.
It's like they opened the playbook and then they just go,
they fan through every fucking page and then they're like,
and that's the game plan for the,
they were going to run this season.
Any questions on two on two ready break.
Right.
And you're like,
what the,
what the fuck just happened?
So,
um,
I believe they got me so fucking paranoid.
I watched this Mario Batali one where,
uh,
he had his friend do it and um,
you know,
he's got,
he's going to show you to make Gnocchi.
You,
you just look up,
just look at Mario Batali fucking blog blog.
You'll see the thing,
they fly through him mixing the shit.
And uh,
but the big thing that kept saying was,
is don't over mix it.
Don't over mix it.
You're going to get a tough pasta,
Yada,
and all that shit.
And these fucking assholes.
They just blew right through it.
And then I under mixed it,
I forgot and I'm starting to feel like I already told you this one.
I told you this,
right?
And he said,
you should make pasta anymore,
you know?
There you go.
There's my supportive wife.
I swear to God.
Do you ever wonder why the woman that loves you is always shitting on everything
that you do?
You know,
not everything you do,
but anything new,
you're trying.
They fucking shit all over you.
You know what I think that is?
I think that there's some sort of fucking paranoia within a relationship.
Maybe guys do it too.
I never dated a guy,
you know?
You know what?
I think I'm going to try this thumb.
Do
you guys still like me?
If I dated a guy for like three fucking months?
You know what?
If I dated like my doppelganger,
I'm trying to get the most fucked up image you could possibly see to me.
I'll update that guy from fucking,
uh,
we're all wacky in the house over here.
Whatever the fuck the name of that show is,
you know?
Oh,
look at you.
You're,
you're fucking a,
I'm from Malaysia.
Look at me.
I like show tunes.
Hey,
I'm the old school guy from fucking the Korean War,
right?
Am I describing my cartoon?
I can't remember.
Anyways.
Um,
the fuck was I just talking about.
Oh God damn it.
My fucking brain just goes in one straight line and you just gotta keep going.
I gotta keep going.
If I come back around again,
it's just like,
I don't even know where the fuck I was at.
Backup backup was before dating a guy for three months,
but it was after gloomy,
gloomy fucking weather.
Say after the car,
crooked car salesman,
Columbia,
he coming around the money.
You come around the mountain,
we going up and down.
Lou,
remember that Mary Tyler Moore won when Lou grant,
he had a great fucking idea and he came and he just forgot about it as,
oh man,
it had the best idea and Mary Tyler Moore is trying to get him to remember.
She goes,
okay,
you're in the elevator here in the valley coming up,
coming up here,
and she's going,
yeah,
yeah.
I was in the elevator.
She goes,
yeah,
you know,
you,
you press the floor,
you coming up,
you're in the elevator and you would think any,
right as he almost gets it.
Ted Baxter just leans in,
he goes,
well,
you're going up or down low.
Oh,
speaking of that shit,
you know what I watched the other day,
I watched an episode of Gilligan's island,
the ones that were in black and white instead of watching March madness,
because I don't like the first couple of rounds.
I know there's all those upsets,
but I don't like watching fucking bunker hill community college playing Duke.
I know every once in a while they get beat and I guess there was a bunch of
fucking upsets,
you know?
I know that one fucking that,
that,
uh,
that Austin Austin city limits college with that fucking,
I couldn't tell if he was a lumberjack or a hipster,
that fucking jacked white dude with the psycho beard man and the Hitler youth
haircut.
I was like,
that guy needs to one more wind and they have to have the other team fucking
tipped it in and they lost right at the fucking buzzer.
But,
um,
I was thinking that guy,
he needs to get to one more round and he is going to be,
he's going to be famous.
You know,
I just seem that cause I was looking like I,
uh,
I remember who he is and I assumed if I remember then everybody else is going to
remember because you know,
why wouldn't the whole world think the way I think?
Well Shit,
maybe I should run for president.
I think when you have thoughts like that,
that means that you're,
you're designed to be a world leader.
I have great ideas and I think everybody,
why wouldn't everybody like my ideas and everybody should think the way I think.
And everybody will be good if I am running stuff,
you know,
and everybody will get the same amount of stuff,
except I'll get a little bit more and by a little bit more,
I mean a bunch of hose,
a bunch of doughs.
It's something else about my toes.
Um,
well you know what,
I,
I can't remember what the fuck I was talking about.
I did start talking about basketball,
but you know,
some,
they actually having a little bit of match madness.
The Madness of March is coming down to a Anaheim and I heard the,
uh,
the Duke guys to Dubois to aim to do board.
We come right back based on their own and [inaudible],
um,
are coming to Anaheim at the Hondas.
I think I'm going to go to that.
You know,
who's getting,
I got to two huge fucking shows coming up this weekend.
One in river side and the other one at the terrorists theatre in Long Beach,
California,
which is really no big deal.
It's just a beautiful theater that Richard Pryor,
uh,
taped his first big special in.
That's all.
I'll just be standing on the same stage.
No reason to prepare or be nervous for that one.
I'm freaking out about that one.
I'm not going to lie to you guys.
I just feel like I'm already putting all this pressure on myself that if I don't
have the fucking,
um,
my show of shows data,
I dunno,
the comedy gods going to be like,
yeah,
it is.
These comedians nowadays,
you know,
they're all still in a bunch of fucking tickets,
but then they stink.
They're not the real deal.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
I'm thinking if I,
if I go out tonight,
tomorrow and Wednesday,
right?
To a couple,
two,
three,
okay.
And then Thursday,
right?
I hit the Duke game then on fucking Friday to get my show and Saturday got my
show and just knock those out.
I feel like I'll be all right.
I feel like I could take one fucking day off.
You know,
am I nuts?
My notes,
because I didn't last night.
This is the thing,
I stopped smoking cigars.
So you know what happens when you quit a bad habit?
Something else fucking goes through the God damn roof.
You know what I mean?
It's like if he quit smoking,
you start eating right?
You start boozing,
you start shooting smack,
right?
You say,
I'm going to start cleaning up around the house.
Next thing you know,
you're beating your wife and you know why?
It's because nobody is perfect.
You ever go to a fucking AA meeting?
They're all in their fucking chain smoking and fucking shove.
And donuts down their throat.
This still killing themselves.
They just slid it over to something else.
That's basically,
um,
okay.
The most fascinating people I find is,
is the people that are just 100% straight edge and they eat like a micro macro
biotic microbio whatever the fuck it is.
Macrobiotic diet.
I'm gonna say macro.
You say macro.
I say micro beep,
a Dapa doable.
Um,
those fucking people,
but you know what it is and they don't do anything.
Okay.
They fucking,
you know,
okay.
They drink fucking,
you know,
pure of the most purified fucking water out of a Unicorn Horn or some shit.
Right.
Just the most,
the most fucking clean living ever.
But you know what?
They probably killed themselves with the stress of knowing there's still going
to die.
You know
how,
how do you think you treat yourself when you really think about it?
I think I treat myself like a,
I wouldn't say the way I treat a rental car.
I treat around car pretty good.
I don't beat the shit out of it.
When I was younger,
I used to,
and it's just funny.
They give you a car and you just,
you know,
maybe neutral drops for some reason were considered fucking amazing.
You know,
you just have it in park.
You would,
oh no,
you put a neutral,
they go bill noodle drop and you would just floor it,
get the rpms up to a bought,
oh,
I don't know,
seven,
8,000.
And then you would just slam it into fucking drive.
And you just heard that horrific sound
of,
I don't know what the fuck it is on an automatic Tricia transmission,
you know,
with the standard would be the coolest shit in the fucking engaging in whatever
the fuck and engages in.
I don't fucking know.
Basically gears and slamming into other gears.
Okay.
I can't believe the teeth just don't fly off on both sides.
I imagined the eventually they do,
but uh,
we used to do shit like that.
Uh,
you know,
you take the car off road,
you could do a lot of shit back in the day before everybody had a fucking
camera,
you know?
Oh.
Speaking of which,
I got to tell you what I fucking saw.
Oh my God.
I almost forgot to tell you this fucking story.
Let me do a little advertising here first.
Oh,
look at that little teaser.
Um,
remind me to talk about the,
uh,
the fucking local fucking wine thing.
I went on with my wife,
mother in law.
My brother in law.
Um,
all right.
Where the fuck is he advertising here for this week?
Okay.
If you knew Susie,
like I knew Susie.
Oh.
Oh,
what a Gal.
She love her.
They're just kind of calling her a whore.
Oh,
if you knew where the way I knew her,
you mean you're fucked her.
Um,
all right.
Me undies me on d,
he's dry and out.
Yo fucking clams me.
Andy's me undies.
Yeah,
the butcher,
his name was fucking Sam.
He was banging Alison a clam was dry.
He thought he was doing his job.
He didn't know why she had the first pair of fucking me undies.
That was 1968.
So they broke up.
If you asked me,
I thought she went down a different road I made,
she was a lesbian.
All right.
Me Undies,
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear unless you're an animal or a
Matthew mcconaughey.
Right?
But instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his clothes every
day,
um,
your underwear is probably boring me.
UNDIES is here to change that.
Um,
please include the following.
I'm going to,
it's pronounced modal.
Every pair of me undies is made from society,
from sustainably sourced modal of fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
Now,
can somebody tell me where the fuck this shit came from?
This is,
this is from a lab.
You know what I mean?
Please tell me.
There's not a group of people that are forced to go out into the fields and pick
model.
You know,
God knows it's going to be some great music that comes out of that one.
Ah,
nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies me undies dry and out your
ball bag.
Um,
but once you try them on,
you'll understand why they're called the world's most comfortable underwear.
Underwear.
Yeah.
Um,
and if you don't love your first pair of me undies,
they're free.
No questions asked.
I don't understand that.
Why would you keep a pair?
Because you can't give them back.
You know,
you can't have your dried up fucking genital sweat in those,
in the,
in the under carriage of those things.
You can't resell those.
Share your kid.
You put them on the Internet for those fucking people that like to sniff other
people's underwear.
What is with those people where they had dog in their past life?
What the fuck is wrong with them?
I bet they're noses are colt.
The perverts have cold noses.
Um,
anyways,
me has dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a statement
with your underwear.
Uh,
whether anyone can see them or not.
Remember Superman.
Um,
okay.
Shipping in the U S and Canada is free and you can save up to $8 a pair with me
undies.
Subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when you go to me undies,
dotcom slash bursts subscription.
Jesus Christ.
How much Tony Touch you?
Shit your pants every month.
You've got to have a subscription dude.
I bought fucking underwear.
I can't even,
I buy it like,
and I just wear that shit til it's over.
You know what I mean?
I wear my underwear at all I got is just the band going around my waist and
they're like Chris Gatland.
Um,
um.
Anyway,
skip the subscription,
blah,
blah.
That's me.
undies.com/birth for 20% off your first order.
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] all right,
tracker,
smack Kaz smart phones,
smart homes.
Technology has made everything.
Matta,
WIC.
Oh my God,
he's wicked.
Fucking smart.
But losing your stuff's still makes smart people feel really stupid.
I don't think it does.
I think it just makes him frustrated.
I think he just wrote that because it sounded good,
but the copy it built.
Why don't you just read the rest of it?
All right.
Track early makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that locates,
misplace keys while it's bags,
computers,
drug paraphernalia,
whenever you're always leaving around the house but can't seem to find anything
in seconds.
Do you beat your children with the wooden spoon?
Did they try and hide it?
You won't lose it anymore.
You'll be able to beat their ass in a second because tracker will help you find
that blunt object,
just pair of tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything,
fight as precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone,
press the button or tracker and your smart phone rings even when it's on silent.
You know what I just realized?
Somebody
is going to kill their spouse with a blunt object in the house and then they're
going to take it and they're gonna throw it in the river,
but they're going to forget that devices on it and the cops are going to use it
and then they're instantly going to be in the hall of fame of world's dumbest
criminals
with over 1.5 million devices.
Tracker has the largest crowd gps network in the world,
so your last item shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away,
you'll never have to use your brain again.
Never lose anything again with tracker.
Listen to this.
Listen listeners to this shelf,
Jesus,
get a special discount of 40% off your first tracker device.
Go to the tracker,
t,
h,
e t r a,
C K e r.com and enter Promo Code,
Burr Bravo uniform,
Romeo,
Romeo.
The hardest thing you'll ever need to ever have to find is their website,
snickers,
snort.
Go to this,
go to the tracker.com right now.
Enter the Promo code per for the 40% off.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Bar.
All right,
and lastly,
but certainly not leastly,
stamps.com
mailing and shipping are a routine part of your business of running your
business.
Important keeps your operation.
What?
Mailing and shipping are a routine part of your business.
Important Comma keeps your operation going.
Dot Dot,
dot.
But if I feel like this should be way more dramatic,
the way the writing is important keeps your business going,
your business operations going.
But if you're making constant trips to the post office,
that's a routine you need to change.
There's a much more convenient way to do it.
You tell your wife to get off her fat fucking ass and getting up stamps.com
staff,
Satcom Briggs,
all the service of the post office right to your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer.
Print postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail so you can focus on what really matters,
getting shit faced during the day,
growing your business.
I use stamps.com uh,
anytime I sent out any my posters right now.
You can sign up for stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus a hundred $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a
digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
you click on the microphone at the top of the homepage,
not the bottom,
the top,
and you type in Burp.
You are our that stamps.com and Tupper.
All right.
Okay,
so you guys ready for this?
A little fucking safari thing.
You know,
I was doing real good with my fucking posture.
Now I'm sitting on my lower back again.
I need to sit up,
sit up straight,
take,
take God damn charger the fucking Goddamn game here.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
it was my mother in law's birthday and,
it got rained out like a month or two ago.
So we finally rescheduled this thing.
We went on the one of these wine trips out here to Malibu.
Um,
and they had these giant fucking,
like 600 acre ranches out there because I will,
I used to always,
you know,
whenever I'm flying by and I always look over and see all that fucking,
that this basically no place to land.
You know,
I was kinda thinking like,
wow,
that's amazing that it hasn't been developed.
I guess because they're all fucking ranches.
Eventually,
eventually they'll get rid of all the fucking grapes and we'll turn it into a
giant fucking,
I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck you call it,
apartment complexes or whatever.
So anyways,
so we go up there and first of all,
it's so up in the fucking hills,
like the gps isn't working and it actually ends up taking us to this,
this fucking,
um,
parole board thing.
That's in the middle there.
They got the Barb wire fence.
It looks like minimum security thing that we went into it like,
all right,
I don't think this is the fucking a wine place.
So we ended up going back and they have on the farm,
you know,
they have a place where you can just go get boozed,
boost up,
listen to some bands and that type of shit.
And uh,
you know,
there's something about wine drinkers.
You just don't want to be around them.
I don't know that it gives you a brutal fucking hangover.
I like a nice glass,
you know,
sound like fucking,
what's his face start talking about fava beans is somebody's liver.
Um,
I look at Nice glass with a meal,
but that's about it.
But um,
anyways,
so they also have like a safari up there.
The APP like Jakks they have this fucking Giraffe,
they have camels,
they had these,
he moves,
they had all this crazy shit.
You could go up and feed them and all that type of stuff.
So we're up there having a great time meeting these fucking yaks and zebras and
stuff.
And,
um,
and of course,
you know,
they got these giant bull light things and this is fucking jerk off
with these one of these guys,
you know,
that bought like the top of the line loafers,
but they're loafers.
They're these really,
this fucking,
you know,
it's the kind of Shit ric flair would buy as a joke,
right?
Just so we could hold them in some broke guy's face and say that his shoes cost
more than a house.
But this guy was like serious and he's wearing them.
There's like dirt on the ground.
Obviously he's walking around in them.
So all of you know,
I'm over feeding a fucking Yak and all of a sudden I heard the unmistakable
sound of a bull hitting the fucking metal rail of offense.
I don't know why.
I know that sound.
I think it's part of the fucking a caveman DNA that's still left in everybody
that you,
you know,
well you just NC ever have,
I like walk down the street and all of a sudden dogs behind a fence and it
growls and your whole body just fucking gets that tingle.
And you come at,
like I'm telling you,
if you don't,
if you started running right then you probably could run as fast as Bo Jackson.
You know,
that's how fast boat Jackson could run just to gain four yards.
He ran as fast as some of would run if a saber tooth tiger was fucking about
ready to eat them,
you know,
that first fucking step.
Um,
anyways,
I heard that sound and immediately I just,
I was just,
I was already being like,
all right,
I'm going to get fucking
trampled.
Or worst case scenario,
this thing's gonna Hook under my belt and my fucking pants.
You're going to do go down to my ankles as my junk is flapping around like that
poor bastard.
Everybody sees,
oh,
that guy's life is over.
He's fuck.
There's no way to laugh that off.
You ever seen that one?
The bull fucking gets into the guy's belt loop tips some upside down and just
thrash in them around the guy's pants.
Go all the way down to his ankles.
And people went from being like,
oh my God,
that's going to die to everybody.
Just sitting there laughing.
At this guy and uh,
you know,
he's sticking like,
oh my God,
this thing's going to Gore my fucking Dick.
Right?
And,
and you know,
the chick that he finally got the fucking courage to trying to get the courage
to ask up,
ask up,
ask out,
up,
out,
over in whatever you wanted to take this bitch out,
right?
So he probably was awkward.
So he's going like,
you know what,
I'll do something amazing and then that'll give her my tea.
I'll show you how courageous I am.
Right?
So he runs with the fucking bulls and right as she was being like,
you know,
you kind of navy themes,
like he's fun.
All of a sudden he's upside down and then there's his fucking little fucking
little a Schmuck,
right?
It's Jewish people say fucking flopping around.
And it was just over that guy not only had to leave his hometown,
his providence,
he had to leave the country.
He might've had to leave the continent.
But now with fucking youtube,
it's just,
you know,
and here I am talking about it,
right?
Sex offenders have an easier time relocating.
Then that fucking guy after that one.
So anyways,
um,
so I hear that sound and right as I turn around,
I see the bull coming off the fence and I see this guy in loafers,
you know,
had run back away from the fence.
Right.
And well it was funny was I went over there and I fed the fucking both and
nothing happened.
Came over there.
I had a relaxed energy.
I fucking,
you know,
I had my fucking weight on my back foot,
I was standing like a fucking box or you know,
I wasn't standing there flat footed like loop through him and that fucking thing
comes,
I'm going to fall on my ass.
I was already anticipate.
It's like I am not ending up in a fucking youtube video.
I'm already a white guy and we,
I already,
I am prone to walking up to animals like their dogs.
I don't know why,
why people do that,
but I do that.
I see a line at the zoo and I want to go up and give it a belly rub.
Oh,
Julian,
oh fuck.
A keto based.
Right.
Where other groups of people,
for some reason they,
they understand not even for some reason what they're doing is common sense.
Whatever fucking reason.
White people,
we just want to go up,
you know,
I dunno,
it's fucking stupid.
Generally speaking,
right?
So,
um,
I'm like,
what a fucking idiot.
And you see the guy,
he's got that look on his face.
Like I know it's got hit in the face by fucking Bull Horn,
right?
And a surprisingly the guides didn't say Shit,
And then we're all going to get back on the little soft open thing,
a safari truck.
And I had boom,
I hear it again in
the same fight.
Look around again,
same fucking guy back peddle and an the stupid loafers and they don't say a
fucking word to this guy.
So I'm just like,
this guy is a fucking moron,
right?
So we'd get on the thing and I were driving over and now we're going to go see
this giraffe is teenage giraffe named Stanley the coolest fucking giraffe you're
ever gonna meet.
It just was not afraid of people whatsoever,
which of course is dangerous.
First thing I thought of when I fucking saw the giraffe was like,
I remember seeing a giraffe on youtube kick.
A fucking lioness is Linus went to jump on the things back and it timed it
perfectly.
Okay.
Like Andre Agassi's fucking dead dead fucking shot.
He used to do right up.
The fuck is not the baseline right up the fucking whatever.
He used to rip that back.
Hey,
now push right up and you know he always talked shit about it.
Made a lot of money with that shot,
right?
That's what the fucking giraffe did.
But what?
That's leg kick the Linus and what are they?
How much does the line wait?
Like 600 pounds,
dude.
He sent this fucking thing.
It looked like it was doing,
like it was in the middle of doing a jumping jack and it was just,
but it was just like doing this airborne cartwheel and it never came down in
this thing.
Fucking flipped around like three times and it hit the ground and it did not get
up.
All right.
I know I use this reference a lot,
but you remember the last hit Brett Farve took?
That's what this lioness looked like from a giraffe.
I couldn't believe it.
Like I jumped up when I saw it,
you know,
it was like watching the nerd beat up the bully.
All these guys were piling on and what was funny when the other lions saw that
they were all like,
oh shit,
I didn't know.
I didn't know the giraffe could do that.
Yeah.
Who was like the Bruce Lee fucking was at the one inch punch when he'd send
somebody flying across the room,
we get it bill.
So that's,
that's all I'm thinking is I am not getting anywhere near that thing's fucking
likes of,
of course they got like a 10 foot fence and then you walk up.
The thing was 16 feet high as a teenager.
Right.
And you go all the way up and all right.
At that level it's just,
it's head and you have feeding it,
little pieces of banana and all that shit with the skin.
They just cut it up in sections and the way it would eat.
It looked like an old man that took its dentures out and it was adorable.
And you know,
deep fucking pet that thing on its head,
it was perfect.
Right?
But anyways,
as what palling up to go see this shit,
the guide goes,
all right,
he goes,
now look those camels over their egos.
You gotta be careful with those things.
He goes,
they're very aggressive.
Um,
you know,
all they want is food,
but if you don't have food,
they're going to,
you got a great chance that they're going to bite you because they're going to
get it one way or another.
It's just how they're wired and their necks are longer than you think.
So don't be,
you know,
turning your back on him,
trying to get a Selfie,
cause you're gonna get bit,
and he goes in as much as I say this,
you know,
a couple,
two or three people a month get bit,
right.
So he says this all right.
Right.
And all I was thinking was good fellas.
Right?
And after all our,
yeah,
yeah.
Bullshit.
What does she do?
She makes a fucking phone call from the home phone,
right?
Exact same fucking thing.
There was these three women in front of us and for whatever fucking reason,
like the second he gave that speech,
I was like,
you know what?
Fuck those camels.
I'm not going anywhere near him.
I didn't try to feed him.
I didn't do it.
I'm not fucking gonna feed stuff.
When the tour guy goes,
we're fucking three people get bit a month.
I'm just like,
you know what?
Guess who's not going to be one of those three.
Oh freckles over here.
Alright,
so we go,
everybody,
pets,
the giraffes.
We look at these fucking emails,
which are the creepiest goddamn animal ever.
I Dunno,
they do.
They have a look on their fucking face.
I can't even,
I can't,
I'm trying to describe.
Okay,
the look.
It's like,
okay,
just imagine if like
you were in your backyard and you were just drinking a glass of lemonade and all
of a sudden you saw the ground moving
in.
A person just came up from under the ground.
Just imagine how dirty their face would be.
And as they walked towards you to take a sip,
eliminate,
just imagine that,
look on their face.
That's what it looked like.
I went to feed one of those things and it fucking came walking over like a
Zombie.
Like I don't know what it was.
And they got this thing where they don't,
they can't like,
just gently take shit.
They go,
they do like fucking pit viper life.
Like their fucking head comes right out.
You,
I held this shit out and I,
the second that thing locked eyes on me,
I fucking just drop the carrot and left.
It's like dare,
it's over.
They're still put.
And the thing was too dumb to fucking look down crazy.
It was like,
it had like,
I swear to God like that,
that description they have when people are on the front lines in a fucking war,
like world war one,
this thing looked like he'd seen horror.
It's entire fucking life.
And it's just like,
dude,
you know,
how about I just leave it here on the top of the fence and you figure it out.
So anyways,
so we'll walk them back to the,
um,
to the little safari truck and those three fucking lay.
Where are they at?
Everybody.
Where do you,
where do you think that they're at?
You'd think that getting on the truck,
you know,
you'd think they're getting ready to go enjoy a glass of fucking wine at the
winery.
No,
they're over by the fucking camels and their fucking getting really close,
but they got carrots to,
they're okay,
but they're way in this thing's fucking wheel house.
Okay.
And I'm just sitting there going like,
and I literally moderate Tinea.
I go near filmless cause one of them is going to get bit,
one of them is going to get bit so
the cutest one of 'em.
All right.
Fucking what does she do after this guy says,
don't turn your back and try to take a selfie.
What does this fucking woman,
she turns her fucking back.
She's in this thing's fucking wheelhouse.
She was so close to the thing,
it almost had to double back with it's fucking neck,
which is what it did.
If fucking wants it realized it didn't have any more carrots.
It.
She didn't,
it fucking doubled back and fucking basically bit this woman right on our boob,
her left Boob,
she had a jacket on and she doesn't want like and fucking stepped away.
Fortunately it didn't clamp down
and it fucking,
it had,
she had these disgusting like just green soul,
like grass stains and saliva because the thing's fucking eat grass all day and
she gets back to the the thing and she's doing that whole,
Oh God,
the thing just like bit me in the boob.
Right.
And the tour guide,
funniest thing ever.
He just looks at it.
He goes,
ah,
I fucking told you
eight drop the F bomb.
Yeah,
I fucking told you it was my favorite thing that I think I've seen.
I can't remember.
That reminds me of when I was a kid,
if I was part of the last generation,
the last tail part of,
if you slipped on the ice,
it was your fucking fault.
It wasn't the guy's fault.
Okay.
Who had the storefront?
It's like,
yeah,
I used to slippery.
Stupid.
Yeah.
May,
maybe next time you'll fucking be a little more careful.
And then somehow it became,
it became the shop owner's fault that you fucking were walking to recklessly on
ice.
Like it's his ice,
not his ice.
It's made by the Lord.
Right.
That's like Mcdonald's having to make salads.
They took fucking responsibility rather than,
it's like,
no,
it's your fault.
You're fat.
You ordered 50 fucking big Mac.
She can't,
you know,
we're a business.
If you order it,
we're going to give it to you.
You,
you're fucking dope.
You know what?
What do you want to do?
I have to go eat a whole fucking gallon ice cream to fuck is wrong with you.
And they somehow took the responsibility and they started making fucking salads.
It's the stupidest thing I've ever seen in my life.
So anyways,
yeah.
And that,
that guy,
he just,
well,
you know,
I fucking told
Dude,
it was like needle off the record.
I couldn't fucking believe it.
And they didn't say anything.
It was like,
it was like watching Donald Trump and that first debate when he was still funny
before it was just like,
holy fuck this guy's,
this guy might run the country now who's getting no,
he might speak for the company,
he might pretend to be running the country.
That's the real deal.
That's why you can't be too afraid of Donald Trump because at the end of the
dates,
you know,
come on,
come on people.
We all know.
You know,
I'll tell you right now,
if I was fucking Isis,
those fucking dopes trying to sneak into this country and blow people up and
shit.
All those fucking idiots got to do is just get together their money and you just
fucking put some money on Halo Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump,
right?
Yeah.
That's all you gotta do.
And then you buy a little bit of advertising type
okay
on all the major networks and you'll never hear about them again.
That's how people,
that's how those fuckers,
you know,
genetically alter food.
You never fucking hear about it cause they got their fucking money in
everybody's pockets and everybody shuts the fuck up.
So that's what Isis should do.
They should just do that and then they could just walk into this country with
the goddamn bazooka on their back and no one would say shit.
Um,
anyways.
So yeah,
that's what it was like the first debate with Donald Trump where he was just,
they will decide.
He said this about women,
you said that about women.
He said not on,
I said about,
I said that about Rosie O'donnell and they're like,
no,
no.
You said it about other women too and he just got right day.
No,
you're probably right.
It probably right.
That was,
it was over.
He's like,
oh my God.
I think that'd be pretty good.
Ah Yeah,
I fucking told you
no sympathy.
No fucking sympathy.
It was perfect.
It's exactly,
it's exactly what I think most people need.
You know?
Look,
I'm not saying that you shouldn't have empathy.
I'm not saying that you shouldn't have sympathy in that type of shit.
All I'm saying is there,
there is a time and a place for no sympathy and that,
that was it.
That was,
it was,
it was done perfectly,
you know,
and I think she's going to be a better person because of it.
She couldn't even argue.
It's like,
oh,
I fucking told you.
And when you really think about it,
it's like once she cuts,
but I think pippy in the Boob,
it's like,
it's like I just fucking told you it was going to do that.
Like a what?
What do you think he's going to say?
Oh,
we did it.
I'm sorry.
Did it do exactly what the fuck I said
going to do.
Um,
and then that was it.
And then the next thing we did was we fucking went over,
we checked over all these original like fucking airstreams and then we were
drinking wine and like it,
that all happened,
like we got on the train like bitter and the boob.
He said,
well,
I fucking told you.
And then we were drinking wine outside and I was just like,
this might,
this is fucking awesome.
That should be part of the tour.
That was,
I don't know.
Is it weird?
Am I making a bigger deal about it?
That it was so fucking refreshing.
Yeah.
Fuck head.
You know,
that's on you.
All right.
There we go.
Hey,
Billy Belgium at bill.
Big Fan.
Are you planning a trip to Belgium in the fucking future?
Um,
can't wait to see you.
Uh,
life on stage.
Ah,
you came close live.
L I.
V.
E and right now I'm still,
I'm sticking with
that French by the way.
I am,
uh,
on lingo.
I got 23 days in a row,
Michael Jordan,
23 fucking days in a row and uh,
I'm just gonna keep fucking doing this shit.
I tried to get a 200 points a day.
Um,
sometimes I don't buy it.
I get at least a hundred,
although Tuesday it looks like I want to get 10.
I did one lesson.
Oh yeah,
here I am for the week.
I got like one 60,
then I got ten one 82,
10,
200,
one 10 and two 30.
That ain't bad.
Um,
he built,
this isn't about you.
It's about the fucking question.
You're right,
you're right.
I get,
I get distracted.
Where the fuck am I?
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
And there's another way I'm,
I'm trying to learn French.
I go to the Montreal Canadiens website and I go onto the French side and,
uh,
I know sacrilegious,
but I fucking do it.
And I,
um,
okay.
What did I say?
Uh,
something learning the hard way the last time,
like the print days,
uh,
something dear as of the ire.
I can kind of read it.
I still can't fucking speak it.
I stink at it,
but at least I'm getting to the point where I can kind of read,
you know,
at a decent level.
I've been going on youtube and I've been watching these fucking,
you know,
they,
they'd like kids shows.
I swear to God,
I'm going to get put on a list,
but I'm learning.
I'm learning.
I'm fucking read it while they're just going like the cat.
The cat says me out,
you know,
meow cat meow.
Oh,
look at that dog.
Oh Ho,
Ho,
Ho.
They do it all in French,
right?
Little Shit shut.
It was all.
Um,
all right,
big fan.
Are you planning a trip to Belgium in the future?
Uh,
can't wait to see you life alive onstage.
Great Brain Greg.
Humor.
Love your show.
I am absolutely 100% going to get there at some point.
Um,
this year I am planning a tour of Eastern Europe and then my usual run through,
uh,
the widest people of all time from Finland all the way over to Iceland and a,
I'm planning to end in Iceland and uh,
spend an extra couple of days there at the blue lagoon spa and you got to do it
and you should go during the winter when all the fucking tourist or not there.
You want to be there when there's snow on the ground.
I mean,
right now I don't know if the northern lights is still probably missed it by
now,
but like that's one that's like a bucket list thing for me.
I want to go there,
see the fucking northern lights.
When I went there,
I felt like I was on the top of the earth and it was the bluest place I'd ever
been to in my life.
Sky was so fucking blew.
It was crazy.
And um,
okay,
tell he's right to everybody.
You always flies past it,
but he goes right by it.
Just fucking,
you got to go to it.
Um,
I gotta tell you when to take a shower there.
You got Yo,
you are going to taste fucking Selfa.
Um,
that's a little gross,
but other than that,
that's fantastic.
Okay.
So I will definitely be there hopefully by the end of the year.
Our painting of Jesus laughing Dear Billy Christ,
my inlaws have had this.
Hank have had this hanging in their house since I've known them and I get a good
chuckle every time I see it.
Hope you do too,
man.
At least one artist,
his depicts the guy is a jolly man.
Now I gotta go back because I copied and pasted,
pasted it.
Did it copied and pasted.
Oh
yeah.
Yeah.
It doesn't even look like Jesus.
I got a while.
We got to,
we got a tweet that,
uh,
that photo out.
Okay.
What made them laugh like that?
Somebody who's probably like,
hey,
you know,
I uh,
Bang a hooker like you,
uh,
do I still have a chance to get to heaven?
You know,
he could read and laughing like that.
I'm going to be hanging on a cross like me.
They have freckles.
Um,
all right,
I'll definitely,
I'll have to post it.
I'm shitting on my lower back again.
How does this happen?
I just slide down the fucking couch.
Um,
alright.
Girlfriends,
dysfunctional family.
All right,
dear Billy boy.
A huge fan of pockets.
Thank you.
Anyways,
I am a male in his early twenties,
living in a small one bedroom apartment with my girlfriend.
Recently my girlfriend's mother has received a new job position that's much
closer to us and she is currently in the process of looking for a new place in
our area.
Oh,
Ooh.
Gj I am all for my girlfriend being able to be closer to her family.
Why?
Why would you be all for that?
Be All for it if they're cool.
I'm telling you right now,
do not marry anybody who does not have a cool fucking family.
Okay?
Cause those motherfuckers are going to be in your house.
You think you're going to marry her and then Yay.
All right.
Take it easy.
[inaudible] just going to fucking Welser out the door for your wedding.
Now they're going to be calling your house.
They're going to be common over there going,
I want to fucking play with your kids.
Okay?
Those people are,
you are marrying into the fucking family.
So right now I think what you're doing is you're trying to be a modern man,
so you're just automatically going lay.
I don't,
I,
I'm all for it.
I'm all for you expressing your opinions and your mother.
Be right across the fucking street.
Listen,
I'm probably projecting here.
Um,
like I said,
thank God,
thank Christ.
Um,
the lovely Nia has a wonderful family.
thank God,
thank Christ.
Because I know people in that situation,
in that situation,
like fucking misery,
the misery of the family.
Like,
you know,
they retire and then they just move to where you are and then they just come
over all the fucking time and they have no fucking clue how annoying they are.
And then if the wife doesn't fucking say anything,
you're,
you got to step up off dude.
Fucking shit show.
All right.
Recently my girlfriends will blah,
blah,
blah blah.
Uh,
I,
I'm all for my girlfriend being able to be closer to her family as I enjoy their
company as well.
Oh Shit.
You know what?
I didn't read that part.
Sorry.
Uh,
but the whole moving situation is starting to become a bit of a headache and it
starting to impede on our own lives.
Yeah.
See,
you're young,
you're in your early twenties.
Okay.
Here we go.
My girlfriend's mother is currently in between places and might stay with us
during the week.
However,
this is not the worst of it.
My girlfriend has three other siblings that her mother provides care for.
Two brothers and one sister.
Her oldest brother in particular is a bit of a black sheep.
He is easily agitated by the smallest requests like cleaning up after himself or
remembering to lock the door.
He is careless when it comes to using other people's belongings and does not
clean up after himself.
Well,
you know what,
that fuck that he can't stay there then I would,
I would be a bit more forgiving if he was younger than I am,
but he too was in his early twenties.
Like me now having to deal with a family member,
like this may not sound like an issue.
No
Dude,
this is,
this is make them,
I'm breaking out in hives reading this thing.
This is how much of a fucking issue this is.
Uh,
especially if your girlfriend does not address what Dosha brother is.
That's what you need.
Okay.
That's the keys to the castle.
If there's someone in,
you know,
whatever,
if you're a woman dating a guy,
right?
If,
if he has some,
if,
if his sister's a cunt and he won't address it on any level.
I'm not saying he literally has to drop the fucking,
you know the scene up there,
but you got,
you got,
you got to fucking are,
you got to address it.
Okay.
You got a fucking addressing.
All right.
So anyways,
now having to deal with this from up above.
Do with member.
Like this may not sound like an issue today,
but I learned that my girlfriend's mother asked to bring,
okay.
My girlfriend's brother with her to stay with us for a few days.
Let's face it,
will probably be longer than that.
After seeing firsthand how he acts with other people,
especially as family,
I want to say no and be done with it.
But I'm sure this will open up more issues between myself and my girlfriend,
her mother,
and possibly her brother.
Yeah.
It'll bring up greatest shoes.
The fact that her brother's a fucking selfish
dude.
You are right now in the beginning of creating your adult life.
So when you feel no,
you say no.
All right.
And if your girlfriend gets fucking pissed,
then fuck her.
Okay?
If she wants to break up with you,
you know what you did,
dude,
you just,
you've just away from what you know,
what you think.
You're fat,
you're fast forward,
you're fast forwarding through the fucking nightmare,
and you're getting to the inevitable end of the fucking relationship without you
being legally bonded to them,
without you having kids that have fucking look like her and just remind you of
them every fucking time it mind.
You are her.
Every time you see him,
this is what you have to do.
You have to listen to your gut and life.
You've got will tell you,
you saying,
I don't want to do this,
but then what happens is social politeness kicks in.
Ah,
you know,
it's only for a few days,
blah,
blah.
I don't want to fuck all that.
Fuck all of that.
I'm not saying that you have to say it the way I'm saying it,
but you have to have a sit down and just be like,
listen,
I don't mind if you mother stay here,
but I'm not comfortable with your brother.
Stay in here.
And she says,
why it's my brother and be like,
because he's inconsiderate and he's reckless with a personal belongings.
He forgets to lock the door and all that.
And um,
I don't think he's a responsible person and just let it sit there and if she has
a fucking problem with it,
who gives a fuck?
I don't do you not to be disrespectful.
Just be like,
I don't share the,
your viewpoint.
And I live here too when I'm saying I'm saying no,
he can't stay here and then she'll have nothing to say other than,
so you saying you can't stay here.
She'll just start repeating what you're saying.
It'd be like,
that is what I'm saying.
And then you let her huff and you let her puff and do all the fucking shit she's
going to do and you don't let that fucking Douche step into the house.
And let it,
here's the thing dude,
what are you,
what do you have to lose here?
Okay.
Other than your own happiness,
you got to put a value on it anyway.
So let me just continue on here.
Um,
he says after seeing firsthand how he acts with other people,
especially as family.
I want to say no,
but I'm sure there's open up more.
It's just between myself,
my girlfriend,
her mother and possibly her brother as it is an issue with my girlfriend and I
have argued about it in the past.
Oh yeah.
So you've already done it?
Yeah Dude.
All right.
You're already knocked down the,
you already kicked in the door.
Walk in.
What would you do in this situation?
I think I've already said it.
Uh,
and is there any sort of advice you can give me if her brother does come to stay
for a few days,
how should I treat him knowing he probably just get agitated with me telling him
to clean up after himself.
Thanks and go fuck yourself dude.
This is the deal dude.
This is,
this is non negotiable.
This is non fucking negotiable.
Okay.
This is your life.
All right?
And he's a fucking dose.
And
listen man,
if your girlfriend can't see what a fucking asshole this guy is due.
Can you imagine if your brother was like this and it made your girlfriend feel
uncomfortable?
Would your brother be each staying with you?
He makes me uncomfortable.
I don't know.
He's weird.
He doesn't pick up.
He smells my me undies.
Whatever the fuck he's doing.
You'd be like,
that's it.
You can't,
you can't be here.
And when he woke up cause your red jerk off.
All right,
this is super right down the street.
Good luck to Ya.
You know?
MMM.
I got to tell you this.
This,
this might be,
this might be the old right there,
Fred,
for your fucking relationship.
Okay.
You might have to throw down the gauntlet.
All right.
I got to tell you dude,
if this,
if this fucking asshole
is already making you this fucking miserable,
okay?
Just the idea of him staying with you for a couple,
two,
three days.
All right?
Are you really going to marry this woman?
You get to marry into that with that fucking shit show.
Okay.
And they'll be there.
You hit any big name.
Very fucking see him.
Fuck that until he goes out and he fucks his whole fucking life up.
But you know,
and what happens,
you do you,
I'm assuming you,
you're planning on being successful in life,
right?
Which means you're going to go make a big bag of loot and get yourself a whip,
Sorry.
MMM,
no,
you can have a nice car.
You have a nice house,
you know,
beautiful wife again of all that type of shit.
And you know it,
you know what comes to think like,
well,
how come I don't have that?
It's like,
well,
because you didn't work for,
it's stupid and they're not going to think that and they,
they're going to want to come around and they're gonna want fucking handouts.
And if she,
and if,
if that fucking jerk off knows that his sister is a big softy,
she's gonna use her to get to you and all the shit that you fucking work for.
Okay.
I'm painting a very bleak scenario here,
but,
um,
okay.
Dude,
you just,
you say,
no,
he can't stay here.
Okay.
You know,
and if it really comes down to just be like,
listen,
I don't like the guy.
Okay.
And I don't think it's,
I just think it's how he's wired because you turned out great.
You guys both had the same fucking parents.
I don't know what happened to that guy,
but he's a fucking,
I don't say fucking that guy age.
Just like,
I don't want him in my,
I don't want him here.
Your mother can stay a plus that it's only a one bedroom apartment,
you know?
So we're going to be on top of each other and I can't deal with that guy when
I'm at your mother's house.
Forget about in our one bedroom apartment.
I don't want that guy here.
I don't want his balls dangling in our fucking commode.
I don't want his pubes in my shower.
I don't want his hands in my,
on the fridge.
I just don't want him to be,
I don't want him here.
You know what's funny?
I don't even know this guy and I fucking hate him.
There's no fucking way,
dude,
please can you please do this for yourself.
And this is a great exercise to have,
you know,
for both men and women.
You can flip this around,
like learning how to stand up to the person that you're with.
You got to learn how to do that.
And you just,
sometimes you just have to,
you've got to have a fight.
You just have to have a fight.
And um,
and there was a freedom to not giving a fuck in a good way.
What people think about you.
I mean,
do you,
who gives a fuck if some piece of selfish shit doesn't like you?
What the fuck do you,
I mean,
I would just openly,
I don't like you.
Yes,
you,
I don't like you.
I think you were a piece of garbage.
Okay.
And then we looked at his girlfriend.
Looks at your girlfriend or his sister.
He just said,
yeah,
don't worry.
I already told him,
ah,
sir,
please don't let him stay in your place and please write right in and please
tell me.
Please tell me what happened.
Okay.
I don't know why,
but I live for moments like this in life,
you know,
as much as I like making people laugh and that type of thing,
I get even more enjoyment telling pieces of shit.
No,
it's one of the great things and just the look on their fucking face because the
reason why a lot of pieces of shit are pieces of shit because people politely
maneuver around them.
Yeah.
And when you can get that fucking Mitt right in their face,
you know,
put your hand right in their forehead.
That's about far enough there sparky.
Ah,
it's just,
it's one of the great failings in life.
I think.
That's why God made Douche bags.
Just so you know.
Someone like yourself can have that feeling.
I'm really coming off arrogant here for,
you know,
I'm probably the Douche bag too anyways.
All right.
Fiance's wedding plants a day or Billy blue band blue bland.
The fuck is that?
Um,
first let me say,
I can't see,
I can't wait to see you in Orlando on May 7th.
I don't know why I haven't seen you perform live yet,
but you're on my left.
You are the last on my top 10 comedians to see before I die.
Oh Jesus.
There's way more than you should see the net,
but I am,
I am very flattered that I am one of the 10.
Okay.
So he says,
I've been engaged for three years now.
All right.
Dumper.
You don't want to marry her.
Do I really need to read the rest of this?
The fuck is engaged for three years.
He said,
and me and my lady are in the first steps of finally planning our wedding.
I'm,
I am simple and um,
and am okay with something small and would rather save money for our honeymoon
and down payment on the house and let me guess.
She wants to spend a ton of fucking money.
My fiance wants a destination theme wedding.
I'm not opposed to compromise and have a destination wedding,
but she wants to theme to be the Little Mermaid in Hawaii.
She's adamant about this and has these horrible outfits picked out for the whole
wedding party to where?
Including myself as Neptune,
I don't believe this.
I'm calling bullshit.
Okay.
But you know what,
as always I'll read it like it's true.
Um,
I'm 37 and she is 28,
if that matters.
I sincerely love her,
but she won't let this go and I absolutely refuse to go through with that.
I don't want to lose her in my life,
but I've tried everything I can think of to talk her out of it and honestly,
it's a breaker for me.
Please tell me your thoughts and if you have any advice,
I'd be very grateful.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
All right,
well if this isn't a joke question,
uh,
you've been engaged for three fucking years.
Okay,
that's weird.
I think there's something going on there and uh,
you know,
you're,
you're a little bit countries is a little bit rock and roll forever that the old
fucking Donny and Marie show usually sometimes opposites,
you know,
she's that party you,
she completes you.
I don't,
I don't think she's at this.
Okay.
This is a shit show.
If this is true,
you are,
you're,
do you understand that when you inevitably get divorced from this fucking woman
that you are going to get no sympathy from anybody?
They will first be that,
oh my God,
a divorce.
I heard,
you know,
other than losing a loved one,
that's the most stressful thing ever.
But when you tell the story that you dressed like Neptune at your own fucking
wedding,
right?
Then every single,
yeah,
well,
you know,
I fucking told you.
She goes,
yeah dude,
you walk away from it.
You're 37,
you find you'll meet somebody else.
Okay?
You get on it.
You don't have a biological clock.
This is one of the great things about being a dude,
you know,
but it all balances out cause we die eight years before them,
so they get the little,
little bit,
you know,
live a little bit longer sitting in that coffee house,
eating those fucking weird chocolates.
Um,
he said,
oh,
this is somebody else's.
I'm sorry.
I thought that's how he signed off.
Um,
yeah,
I would walk away from this whole fucking thing.
How many more red flags need to be shook in your face.
You just walk away from the whole fucking thing.
Phi.
You see?
Oh my God dude.
What kind of fucking issues does she have that she wants to have a little,
oh my God.
She one of those women that has said Gugu Gaga,
creepy ass fucking voice.
She's talks,
talks like she's fucking six.
Okay.
Oh God,
that gives you the fucking chills.
Can you be a fucking adult over here?
What do you,
what do we do?
You mean what if you wanted a Scooby doo theme?
Fucking wedding,
right?
You wanted her to dress like fucking that with Dell.
The Janeane Garofalo redheaded one,
you know,
and her sister to dress like Daphne and you are going to be fucking shaggy.
The best man was going to dress like Fred with that scarf around his fuck it.
Why don't we,
why?
Why do
I don't believe that question?
I just don't.
Okay.
And if you fucking marry her,
you deserve it.
You know?
And when you come crying up to me,
I'm going to steal from that fucking tour guy I fucking told you.
Alright squatch hey,
Billy Bird legs.
That's fucking hilarious.
I've been listening to you talk about the way you work out of the podcast and I
got to chime in.
Do some fucking squats.
Do squats are not a leg exercise.
They are a compound full body movement.
Oh,
this is already making me tired.
Uh,
put a couple of hundred pounds on your back.
Just push your legs and watch while you're frail.
Freckled spine gets twisted like a pretzel.
Well,
why would I want to do that?
Squats and deadlifts,
which I recommend to a
need you to engage damn near every muscle in your body.
If you want to put on some real muscle density,
stop being such a cowardly little kid and learn to squat and dead lift.
Dude,
I don't want to walk around.
All bulked up,
you know,
start wearing tank tops.
I'm not trying to do that.
Jesus Christ.
He said,
I recommend watching Ed c o h n apostrophe s squat and dead lift videos from
super training on youtube to start to,
I'm not trying to get into the NFL.
Uh,
then watch the rest of their content and learn what the fuck you're doing.
I wrote some stuff about my experience with adding squats and dead lifts to my
routine.
You can read it or not.
Just lift some heavy shit.
Stop being a bitch and go fuck yourself.
All right.
I like the way this man speaks and gets right to it.
He's very direct.
Uh,
my experience when I was younger,
I used,
I used to be a mirror muscles,
guys,
mirror muscle guy to fuck you talking about dude,
I got a peg board.
I got those.
Uh,
Tomic fucking uh,
I'm doing all I'm doing.
I'm trying to do like half.
Um,
what are the,
uh,
American Ninja Warrior fucking thing.
I'm building that in my garage.
All right.
You with your fucking Schwartzenegger workout from 1978 stop acting like you're
in the future.
You fucking cunt.
I was decent.
You know,
you came in,
you were talking a little bit fresh.
You need to fucking stand down a little bit here.
Um,
he said,
I got older and I started working in a chocolate factory.
You know,
everything seems like a lie this,
but you worked in a Cha Cha will you in a fucking tree making cookies.
Amazingly doing car curls and benching one 35 after spending the day sitting at
my desk shoveling free chocolate and my face did nothing to stop my belly from
growing.
Well yeah,
we'll neither were doing squats.
Okay.
If you don't fucking eat anything else but cookies.
Anyways,
he goes,
now I squat bench and deadlift like a power lifter and I am stronger and more
jacked than I have ever bent.
Yeah,
and you stop eating chocolate.
Um,
not only do I actually have legs now,
but my chest arms and back traps,
everything are bigger than ever.
I just,
I can't recommend the videos from super training enough.
All right,
I'll check it out.
The guys are hilarious,
strongest fuck and there,
there is tons of great info on there.
Anyways,
they appreciate the podcasts.
Best of luck with the new home gym.
And again,
go fuck yourself.
All right,
cool.
I will definitely check that out.
Thank you so much for that information.
Once again for people at home.
Ed said Coa and apostrophe s for some reason I don't.
It looks like it's missing something.
But anyways,
it's called a super training.
So if you spell the name kind of like that,
it ought to come up in your,
uh,
your Google search.
They're okay about driving and diving into caves.
Uh,
hey bill,
you were talking divers with those caves.
Here's a documentary of Finnish guys who legally,
illegally,
who go illegally to their dead friends bodies.
What from their last trip?
I think it was made illegal to go there after they die because it was too
dangerous to go to those cases.
But they went anyway and made a movie about it.
Come to Finland soon and go fuck yourself.
Well,
why don't they retrieve the bodies?
Is everybody lying to me this week?
Why can't you be honest?
All right.
The last one here.
A girlfriend is good friends with dude.
She met on Tinder.
Uh,
hey,
Billy red Burke,
uh,
Bork kind of I guess is supposed to be like Ray Bork red book.
Um,
so recently I was talking with my girlfriend about one of her guy friends.
The two of them seem pretty close.
He did a photo shoot for a tee shirt company.
She's starting in and she even said,
we're like the same person.
Yeah,
dude,
it's sour.
It's over.
She hasn't blown him yet.
She's gonna walk away something she's has said,
uh,
something she has said to me as we're talking,
she reveals that she met this dude off of the dating and actually just about
fucking app Tinder before
you wrote this so bad before she,
we got together.
I'm just going to read it how you wrote it.
I tried to play it.
Cool letter,
talk about him and just brush it off as whatever,
dude,
this is the brainwashing of the American male now where everything is,
if you even question a woman,
it's like,
wait,
was that date rape?
So you just ignore all your fucking instincts here.
I tried to play it.
Cool.
Yeah.
Her douche bag brother who does totally inconsiderate,
wants to stay here.
You know,
I'm all for that.
You're not all four that your soul is screaming.
No.
Yeah,
you're playing it cool cause you're not cool with it.
Yeah.
Why don't you go hang out with some fuck buddy.
You met on Tinder and see how she fucking likes it.
Right.
Anyways,
well the two of them texts quite a lot and the other night she received
something I think from him and she laughed.
Now I am ordinarily not a nosy tight,
but the situation is weird.
So I asked what's funny,
she flipped.
She said,
I'm being too nosy and trying to pry into your personal life.
Oh my God.
And then did you give her a sidekick right out of the fucking bed?
He goes,
I mean she really flipped a shit about it.
She claims I'm being paranoid and that they are just friend.
I Dunno Billy.
If they've fucked,
what's to say they want it to,
what do you mean you don't know?
He finishes it with,
am I being paranoid?
Should I not give a shit or should I kick this check to the curb dude.
Punter to the curb.
Right in the seat of a fucking lion pants.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I would just say,
why you breaking up?
I go,
cause you cause the guy on Tinder complete.
You go get with him.
Oh my God,
you're being paranoid.
No I'm not.
You guys are fucking in my heart to hearts.
You guys are fucking,
and if you're not,
you're Gunna,
and to be honest with you,
you probably should be
your fucking laying in bed with me giggling about his God damn texts.
Just go over there and suck his dick already.
They give me my keys.
That's it.
It's fucking over.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you Thursday.